en este vídeo hablaremos sobre el
concepto de distribución muestral
imaginemos que tenemos una población de
pelotas en la cual cada pelota tiene un
número escrito de esta población podemos
calcular algunos parámetros un parámetro
establece una característica real de
dicha población como ya hemos visto en
vídeos anteriores por ejemplo podemos
tener la media de la población la media
de los números escritos en las pelotas
podemos tener la desviación estándar de
la población podemos tener la proporción
de las pelotas que son impares todos
estos son parámetros de la población
hemos visto en otros vídeos que podemos
desconocer los parámetros de la
población o quizá estos no son fáciles
de calcular por lo que para estimar los
parámetros de una población tomamos una
muestra de tamaño n y podemos calcular
un estadístico de esa muestra con base
en ese estadístico podemos tener un
estimado de dicho parámetro eso sí esta
muestra tiene que ser aleatoria cada vez
que tomamos una muestra el estadístico
que calculamos para dicha muestra no
será necesariamente igual al valor del
parámetro de la pobla
si tomamos otra muestra y calculamos el
estadístico podemos tener un valor
diferente todos estos serán estimados de
este parámetro una pregunta interesante
es cuál será la distribución de los
valores que obtengo de estos
estadísticos cuál es la frecuencia con
la que obtengo diferentes valores para
este estadístico con el que trato de
estimar este parámetro esta distribución
es a lo que nos referimos como una
distribución muestral veamos un ejemplo
para comprender esto es un ejemplo muy
sencillo en donde mi población es de
tres pelotas numeradas 1 2 y 3 el
parámetro que nos interesa es la media
de la población que es 1 2 + 3 / 3 que
es igual a 2
digamos que queremos tomar muestras de 2
pelotas cada vez que tomamos una pelota
anotamos su número y la devolvemos a la
población de manera que cada pelota que
tomamos la consideramos como una
elección independiente usaremos esas
muestras de dos pelotas para estimar la
media de la población por ejemplo
tenemos esta muestra de tama
aquí salió un 1 y salió un 2 cálculo el
estadístico de la muestra que es la
media muestral para estimar la media de
la población y para esta muestra de 2 va
a ser 1.5 hacemos lo mismo y ahora sale
un 1 y un 3 en este caso la media de la
muestra es el promedio de 1 y 3 que es 2
pensemos en todas las muestras posibles
que podemos tener y veamos cuáles son
sus medias muestrales para después ver
la frecuencia con la que obtenemos
dichas medias muestrales vamos a dibujar
una tabla aquí estos son los números que
salen recuerden que cuando tomamos una
pelota anotamos su número y la
devolvemos luego tomamos otra pelota y
hacemos lo mismo para que así cada
evento sea independiente ya que hay
reemplazo podemos tener un 1 y un 1 un 1
y un 2 un 1 y un 3 1 2 y un 1 1 2 y 1 2
1 2 y un 3 o un 3 y un 1 un 3 y un 2 o
un 3 y 1
hay tres pelotas posibles para la
primera toma y tres pelotas posibles
para la segunda toma cuál es la media de
la muestra para cada una de estas
combinaciones para esta es uno para esta
es 1.5 para esta otra es 2 para esta es
1.5 para esta es 2 para esta es 2.5 para
esta es 2 para esta es 2.5 y para esta
es 3 ahora podemos graficar la
frecuencia con la que aparecen estas
medias muestrales y esta gráfica es la
distribución muestral de las medias
muestrales vamos a hacerlo aquí ponemos
las medias muestrales posibles
11.52 2.5 o 3
ahora veamos sus frecuencias de los 9
resultados posibles cuántos son iguales
a 1 tenemos sólo 1 lo ponemos en la
gráfica como 1 de 9 y lo dibujamos aquí
cuantos resultados hay iguales a 1.5 hay
dos de estas nueve posibilidades lo
ponemos aquí cuantos resultados iguales
a 2
y tenemos 12 y 33 resultados de los
nueve posibles
aquí tenemos tres de nueve en la gráfica
ahora veamos cuántos 2.5 hay 1 y 2 son 2
de 9 lo ponemos aquí otra forma en la
cual podemos ver esto es que cuando
tomamos una muestra aleatoria con
reemplazo de dos pelotas tenemos una
probabilidad de dos novenos de tener una
media muestral de 2.5 finalmente tenemos
un solo caso en el que podemos tener una
media muestra igual a 3 así que lo
gráfica moss en esta parte esto de aquí
es la distribución muestral de la media
para muestras con un tamaño de 2
nos vemos en otro vídeo